hoy les voy a decir algo
que posiblemente nunca hayan escuchado
en su vida
algo con lo que posiblemente no estén de
acuerdo conmigo no quieran aceptar
ten miedo
corre grita llora aterroriza
a dónde voy con lo que te acabo de decir
a lo largo de nuestra vida nos han
enseñado una cosa muy importante que es
que para alcanzar nuestras metas tenemos
que vencer nuestros miedos
solamente las personas que logran
enfrentar con este obstáculo son quienes
emprenden y lideran el mundo
para casados
se caen en el olvido
siempre me ha preguntado
tiene que ver el miedo con intentar y
cumplir tus sueños
siempre nos han enseñado que el miedo es
algo malo algo que se puede personificar
como una sombra que llega a los momentos
menos oportunos que nos toma en la mano
y no nos deja ir que nos arrastra si el
declive
y que la única manera que tenemos para
enfrentar esta sombra es negando que
está ahí
y yo les pregunto
el miedo es algo malo
es algo malo
porque no nos han enseñado que es una
parte esencial de nuestra naturaleza que
podemos aceptar para así canalizar
no podemos negar algo que va a llegar en
algún punto de nuestra vida y que muchas
veces ni siquiera vamos a saber por qué
gracias al miedo seguimos con vida
gracias al miedo no metemos las manos al
fuego
gracias al miedo nos movemos y buscamos
un lugar seguro
el miedo nos unía y nos une a esta
persona que siempre estará para nosotros
las unidades chiquitos cuando corríamos
de la oscuridad hacia nuestras mamás
incluso a la fe cuando vemos una araña
en el baño
el mundo en el miedo nos une con la
realidad del mundo con la vulnerabilidad
que tenemos como
voy a contar una historia
el semestre pasado yo venía en el
transporte de la escuela con una amiga
de camino a mi casa y venía contando que
si iba a estudiar la carrera a canadá
tenía mucho miedo
porque pues no conocí a nadie allá no
sabía cómo moverse por la ciudad no iba
a estar su familia pues no tenía ni idea
de que iba a ser de ella una vez estando
allá
pero estaba muy emocionada
dentro de esta misma plática y todo
salió de una compañera suya también se
iba a ir a estudiar la carrera a canadá
a otra parte del país la universidad de
sus sueños le ofrecieron una muy buena
beca
y yo me preguntaba
la universidad de tus sueños la carrera
que quieres te ofrecieron una muy buena
beca del extranjero
para esto mi amiga me contesta
porque no conocía a nadie
porque no sabía cómo moverse por la
ciudad porque no iba a estar su familia
porque no tenía ni idea de que hubiera
sido de ella una vez estando allá
yo me pregunte
qué diferencia a mi amiga con su
compañera si las dos estaban pasando por
una situación similar tenían exactamente
el mismo miedo
la respuesta es muy fácil
su compañera no entendía que el miedo
era algo natural algo que iba a llegar
parte de la naturaleza y esencia humana
el miedo al cambio
no lo entendían lo negó lo rechazó lo
dejó atrás de ella y lo intentó suprimir
y lo único que logró porque la
consumiera se pusiera enfrente de esta
sombra y que tomará una decisión por
ella que la acompañara
y todo su futuro
mientras
que mi amiga entendía que esto era una
parte normal algo que iba a llegar que
no podía controlar del todo
lo acepto
no dejo que el miedo decidiera por ella
por eso yo les digo
el miedo no es algo malo
incluso podemos utilizar este
sentimiento a nuestro favor para
emprender y salir de nuestra zona de
confort podemos aceptarlo
podemos aceptar que el miedo va a llegar
pero lo que no podemos hacer es dejar
que tome protagonismo en nuestra vida y
que decida por nosotros podemos aceptar
el miedo y podemos llevarlo con nosotros
a todos lados
vamos a aceptar que el miedo va a llegar
cuando queramos tomar una decisión
importante en nuestras vidas
saber que el miedo va a llegar cuando
queramos cumplir nuestros sueños pero
llevarlo contigo hasta llegar a esa meta
saber que el miedo se va a presentar a
ese examen de admisión o a este proyecto
de vida pero llevarlo contigo hasta
hacerlo
podremos llevar el miedo a todos lados
siempre y cuando no dejemos de ir a
donde queramos
llegamos el miedo de cambio a una
revolución
vemos nuestro miedo de fracaso a nuestra
búsqueda de oportunidades llevamos
nuestro miedo de tener un país a manos
de la violencia a nuestra lucha por la
justicia social